wir schalten jetzt zu meiner kollegin
jasmin jahres sie ist in bielefeld in
nrw sollten heute 53 impfzentren
eröffnen doch jasmin das läuft nicht
ganz nach plan aufgrund des wetters ja
genau patricia video schon gesagt hast
heute ist es endlich soweit 53 ins
zentren in nrw haben endlich geöffnet
lange hat man auf den stoff gewartet
jetzt ist er da aber nachdem im chaos
kommt jetzt das schneechaos und der
macht es eben den menschen über 80
jahren also dem impf berechtigten
wirklich schwer
hierhin zu kommen und sich impfen zu
lassen wir konnten vor einer stunde
ungefähr mit einem ehepaar sprechen die
sich wirklich durch den schnee gekämpft
haben um sich hier impfen zu lassen
vielleicht können wir da einmal
reinschauen
wir hatten schon aufgegeben und dann hat
meine frau noch mal nach einer stunde
taxi gerufen und da ist sie dann zum
ziel gekommen
wir wurden am berg oben wir hätten auch
kein auto nehmen können also es war
nicht anders möglich auch zu fuß war es
zu weit also taxi war schon aber die
unsere einzige möglichkeit und ich habe
sehr intensiv auf meinen termin gewarnt
jetzt wie lange die berater na ja wir
haben uns 22 oder so und ich bin krank
und insofern bin ich wirklich dankbar
dass ich jetzt gleich dran kommen
impfen auf jeden fall wichtiger
geschmäcker als alles ganz ganz wichtig
ja ich stehe jetzt hier im impfzentrum
in bielefeld die schneemassen gibt es
draußen die erwarteten massen der impf
berechtigten die bleiben hier leider aus
wie man gerade sehen kann also die zwei
stunden die wir jetzt hier sind haben
wir gefühlt 20 menschen gesehen die sich
impfen lassen möchten genau hier vorne
sieht man vielleicht dort ist die
anmeldung hier registrieren sich die
leute bekommen nochmal das fieber
gemessen und dann geht es hier weiter in
die halle
hier können wir jetzt sprechen mit dem
einsatzleiter des heutigen tages und
zwar mit herrn speck vielleicht herr
speck könnten sie uns einmal sagen wie
war der start etwas holprig durch den
schnee
er war gar nicht so holprig wie erwartet
also natürlich wenn wir uns darauf
eingestellt und sind davon ausgegangen
dass ganz viele leute nicht kommen
verspätet kommen wie auch immer und ich
muss sagen die der start lief nahezu
reibungslos es war so gut gefüllt wie
wir es erwartet hatten wobei die
einschränkungen daran ist dass die dass
viele leute ihre termine sozusagen so
ein bisschen frei jetzt heute genommen
haben und deutlich früher kam als
eigentlich geplant so dass die leute die
ausgefallen sind die gibt es in der
ersten stunde definitiv nicht
ausgefallen aufgefallen sind und jetzt
gerade wird es deutlich ruhiger weil
wahrscheinlich die meisten wie heute
dann unbedingt wollten ihren termin
schon hinter sich haben runabout wie
viele menschen kamen heute also ich kann
nur sagen in den ersten anderthalb
stunden waren es ungefähr 70 dass damit
sind wir sehr zufrieden gerade bei dem
wetter damit so eine zahl hat mir nicht
gerechnet es wird jetzt weniger ich kann
das noch nicht hochrechnen wie viele es
werden aber ich schätze dass für eine
auslastung vielleicht von 60 70 prozent
haben am abend ja vielleicht könnten sie
noch einmal erzählen wie geht es dann in
den nächsten tagen weiter der schnee hat
natürlich nicht auf die menschen müssen
trotzdem hierhin kommen gibt es da
irgendwie sowas wie ein shuttledienst
oder der dauerfrost kommt zusätzlich
dazu ja es gibt hier in bielefeld
tatsächlich einige organisationen die
sich ehrenamtlich um sowas kümmern das
geht aber speziell vor allen dingen auch
im terminvergaben wirklich ein
shuttledienst gibt es nicht es gibt das
normale anschreiben von der stadt
bielefeld dass die leute wenn sie
berechtigt sind diesen taxischein
kriegen
der anteil ich dann halt verrechnet wird
aber im wesentlichen ist eigenanreise
weiterhin erforderlich wobei wider
erwarten dass die witterung sich
zumindest stabilisiert und das dann auch
die bus und bahn irgendwann ihren
zeitplan wieder drin haben
taxen fahren ja ohnehin mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren